I looked across the street and in the
driveway I think it was a Bronco looked
a lot like the car that my dad would
drive when he would come and visit and
then I noticed it again and I noticed it
again next time my dad came and visited
I matched it up I mentioned to my mom I
go hey
I noticed that dad's car is in this one
House's driveway a lot when we pick up
you know Jeff Lewis on the school bus it
was that close yeah literally right
across the street my mom like Turned
pale white and she sat me down and she
told me everything then she decided to
stop the lies then and break down
everything that this 10 year old boy
that's a lot yeah so what happens when
you hear this she ended up calling him
he ended up coming back and this and
that and we had him there's a guy walk
over right